[Music]
kylie jenner and travis scott had a
parents night out
i love it and e.t has new details on
what went down inside the rapper's
birthday bash
[Music]
over the weekend in miami kylie was on
hand to help travis celebrate his 29th b
day
at the city's iconic hotel the fountain
blue
the makeup mogul shared these videos to
her instagram story
living it up inside the club
and et has learned not only did travis
perform he was also the party's dj
[Music]
a source tells us kylie was seated
behind the dj booth
which allowed travis to chat with her
throughout the party the source adds
that kylie and travis were visibly
together
and definitely seemed to enjoy each
other's company
this latest sighting follows new details
we learned about kylie and travis's
relationship status
i don't feel any different but it's fun
in february a source told et they still
act like they're an item
and along with daughter stormy the trio
are relatively inseparable for the most
part
the source added neither of them are
interested in dating others at this time
and that there's little to no drama in
their co-parenting
kylie and travis began dating in 2017
and have maintained an on-again
off-again relationship ever since
and speaking of birthdays
[Applause]
in february kylie and travis went all
out to celebrate stormy turning three
the party was complete with an enormous
slide modeled after stormy's face
and a table fit for a queen and look at
this
kylie shared a video of the birthday
girl showing off some royal etiquette
you